hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about thy seating
what we know about it how we think it's
acting and take a look at some of the
clinical trials that are currently being
conducted using physin
looking at both the dose and bio
availability and then lastly i'll give
my verdict
so first then what is phyton well physin
is a naturally occurring flavonoid
here is its structure and you've most
likely eaten
fiben because it's found in apples
grapes
onions cucumbers and has the highest
amount in strawberries
these amounts are still quite low though
and the average daily intake of
naturally occurring this eating is
estimated to be around 0.4 milligrams
per day
so physician is a polyphenol then
similarly to resveratrol and quercetin
in fact the chemical structure of physin
is very similar to quercetin
differing only in a hydroxyl group in
position five and it's important that
you remember that because we'll be
coming back to both physician and
seating later on in this video but for
now we're gonna go back in time
back to a nature publication that was
published in 2003 that identified
activators of a protein known as cert
one
background to this research is nicely
explained in davidson cloud's book
lifespan
they had recently identified that extra
copies of the yeast equivalent of cert 1
sir 2 extended their lifespan as they
were interested in
identifying compounds that could
activate this protein
this would enable them to increase the
activity of cer2 without having to add
additional copies of the gene
at the same time conrad howards was
trying to identify inhibitors of sat1
the human equivalent
because having inhibitors to different
enzymes helps researchers to try and
understand what these different proteins
are doing
moreover it's more common to identify
compounds that can inhibit a protein as
opposed to activate it
so excitingly in his research he
identified two chemicals that actually
activated
sat1 activity the first one was physin
and as we saw earlier that physin is
chemically similar to quercetin
physin is also quite similar to the
polyphenol resveratrol
and so in this nature study they
effectively end up showing that
resveratrol is superior to
physin in terms of activating cert-1 but
this is just the beginning of our
understanding of physician
as physician like other polyphenols seem
to have a variety of different functions
within a cell
and it's not necessarily clear what
their precise targets are
or how many targets they have within a
cell and so more recent work suggests
that physician may have senolytic
properties
so what is analytics well cinelytics
are a class of drugs that selectively
clear senescent cells
now you've likely heard senescent cells
be described as
zombie cells but effectively senescent
cells are cells that have entered the
state of cell cycle arrest
that is they've stopped dividing and
instead they often seem to be secreting
this inflammatory phenotype
referred to as the senescence-associated
secretory phenotype
whilst it's initially thought that these
inflammatory factors can help to bring
in
immune cells to get rid of these
senescent cells their accumulation can
occur during aging
and result in this chronic inflammation
that can cause a variety of
age-associated diseases
you can see a list of these different
diseases here it's pretty exhaustive
and so the hope is that xenolytics that
selectively
kill these senescent cells may be able
to
provide a therapeutic benefit to people
with these different diseases
and also given that cellulosin essence
is a hallmark of aging it's also
potentially thought that xenolytics
could be useful
to help extend health span or even
lifespan and so the word that i keep
emphasizing
is selective and so the idea is that you
want these cenotics to target senescent
cells and not your healthy normal cells
and the second thing is that our
understanding of stenolytics is that
instead of them targeting one specific
protein or molecule within the cell it
seems to be targeting
senescent cells as in it seems to be
targeting a senescent
network that gets perturbed on the
addition of synalytics and causes it to
die
and so this brings us back to physin
where its cellulitic potential was
further tested
in this 2018 paper physician is a
cenotherapeutic that extends healthspan
and lifespan
and so the first thing they did in the
study was to compare the effects of
physician to other flavonoids
in terms of its therapeutic effects and
cells induced
into senescence by oxidative stress and
so they used the kind of more fake term
stenotherapeutic as in this initial part
they were just trying to look at
how the number of senescent cells varied
on addition of these different
flavonoids
and so if you look in the figure here
you can see that physician compared to
their control
greatly reduced the number of senescent
cells present
and so therefore supporting the
centrotherapeutic potential of physin
it's interesting to note though that
quercetin didn't
and so two kind of main points come from
this firstly
it's the understanding that senescent
cells can be induced in a variety of
different ways
and semester cells are very different it
depends on their context
how they are induced depends on their
cell type and so different
potential analytics may be targeting
different sets of senescent cells
and then secondly often if you look at
studies for example this study i
mentioned
before where it was an alzheimer's
disease model where they looked at
removing senescent cells here they used
a combination of quercetin and the
satinib and so obviously they just had
question alone here so maybe it isn't
surprising that alone quercetin didn't
have
as great an impact on the reduction of
senescent cells as physician
but it's crazy how similar those
structures are yet the results are so
different here
but anyway these are in featuring models
in the study they also did a variety of
in-fivo tests
the first one that i want to mention
here is in a projeroid mouse model that
also possesses a reporter
that enables you to detect cells that
have high expression of p16
p16 being a gene that's commonly
upregulated in senescence
and so in these mice they can
effectively use this reporter to
identify senescent cells
and so in this figure here you can see
quite strikingly that the addition of
physician
which they only gave to the mice
intermittently so they gave them
from weeks six to eight and 12 weeks of
age
um this being a project model so they
age faster than normal mice
and even with this intermittent
treatment whereby they were given five
seating in their
child diet so they were having roughly
60 milligrams per kilogram for
5 season per day during these time
periods and at 12 weeks
you can see quite a striking difference
in the luminescence
levels which is how they detect p16
expressing cells
and so this seems to be suggesting
physicians sonolytic potential
and moreover in this graph you can see
that consistently throughout these
different weeks
the number of senescent cells detected
by the
luminescence is always lower in the
flyseason diet compared to the control
diet
and so the thing that they also point
out in this paper is that
even in the weeks where they weren't
getting any physician you still see a
significant difference between the
control and
the thickening diet suggesting that
intermittent treatment
may be effective as a so-called
hit-and-run whereby you can have short
bursts or fiction treatment to get rid
of senescent cells
and then do it again once more if
accumulated and this
comes down to the kinetics of the fact
that physician seems to have
pretty much an immediate impact on the
senescent cells
whereas senescent cells can take much
longer weeks to months to accumulate
and the other interesting thing they did
in the study is that they gave this
eating in their diet
to aged mice beginning at 85 weeks of
age
so in human terms i mean it's always
hard to try and translate but it's
roughly 75 years in humans
and so they gave this to 85 week old
mice
and you can see that it seemed to extend
the lifespan of these mice
and they also did a couple of
measurements to look at their health
span
albus is not the best set of
measurements but they did show
that physician reduced oxidative stress
in the liver of the old mice
and if you want a more extensive look at
this research paper then you should
check out life extensions advocacy
foundations journal club where they do
discuss this paper
but the last bit of data i want to show
you is when they looked at how
physician impacted human adipose tissue
whereby they treated these tissue
explants
with 20 micromelar or physician for 48
hours
and so this tissue typically contains
senescent cells
and you can see here that it caused a
significant reduction in
these inflammatory markers of the
senescence secretory phenotype
including interleukin-6 and
interleukin-8 but i also
suggest that there could be some
translational potential of fryseating
to humans and so this now brings us on
to clinical trials that are currently
being conducted
using physin in different human diseases
and so one of these trials
is being conducted by james kirkland's
team at the mayo clinic
with the title alleviation bifocation of
frailty
inflammation and related measures in
older adults
where physician will be administered
orally in doses up to 20 milligram per
kilogram
for each patient and they're also
looking at just an acute treatment with
physician giving them orally for only
two consecutive days
and so i also said at the beginning at
some point i'd come back to the bio
availability of physietin
and sophistin is a hydrophobic molecule
that means it's
effectively terrified scared of water
basically it doesn't want to
associate mixed with water and so
dissolving on water is
pretty hard for something like physin
whereas polar solvents like oil
are favorable and so it doesn't really
say in this
study how they're actually delivering it
and so in addition to its
low bio availability in water physicians
also quite rapidly
metabolized and so i don't know how
that's going to impact their study but
i guess they're also things they'll
probably be trying to look at in these
sorts of studies
but there's another clinical trial in
the work that's also using the same
amount of physin
this time trying to improve skeletal
health from older humans
and there's also another clinical trial
that's trying to look at osteoarthritis
and whether physician can alleviate
those symptoms which will be interesting
given the failure of uv exo101
anyway the other thing that's worth
mentioning is that there's also a
clinical trial to use physin for older
hospitalized covered 19 patients
to prevent progression to cytokine storm
and acute respiratory distress syndrome
and so that got fda approval recently
and the motivation for the study came
from
previous data that seems to be
unpublished where physician reduced
mortality in mice infected with mouse
beta coronavirus
and so there's a lot of potential for
physician but it's impossible to know if
rice eaten treatment
will be beneficial or harmful without
some of this data coming out
and it's hard to say if that data will
even give us these answers
given the fact that they seem to be
doing acute doses of fighting
but maybe acute is all you need i guess
we'll just have to wait and find out
and so this is in line with james
curcland who's behind the majority of
these different trials that says until
such studies are done it is too early
for analytics to be used outside of
clinical trials
so i guess i'll just have to wait and
see but in this quite extensive
article that i recommend you read if
you're interested in physician
showed that giving mice really high
amounts of physician or giving the
myspicine in their diets for nine months
didn't seem to show
any toxicity and so that does give some
hope that
phytation could be safe i mean it's also
an actual product found in foods
but again we won't know for certain
until the trial data comes out
so with that i just have to give a shout
out to my patreon tina
and i hope you've learned something on
this video and as always
thanks for listening